Getting into a bit more detail now with the animation editor.
So we have the overall user interface here with the animations.
We're talking about key frames so you can add additive animations and also curves to
this interface.
So you see the list of animations on the bottom right hand side there of all the animations
that you currently have.
You can add notifications.
So a classic example of this with animation notifies would be if you have a standard walk
animation and every time the foot hits the ground you want to notify Unreal to maybe
play a sound or something like this.
So you could add a notify of every time the foot plants on the ground to then send a message
into Unreal somewhere.
You can also record animations in this editor window as well.
So the animation editor with the asset browser.
So on the bottom right hand side, you have all your assets.
You can pop this out into its own window if you wanted to.
You can just drag and drop the windows however you want to layout the information.
But you can browse all the animations that you currently want to use and preview them
there inside the animation editor with the use of the asset browser.
So useful to kind of preview your animations that you've got here.
If you are editing the animation in Sequencer, you can edit with Control Rig here.
So you just want to use that drop down option and use edit with FK Control Rig and then
you'll get a baked to Control Rig pop up notification.
So you can edit your animations via the edit in Sequencer option in this instance.
When we're talking about Sequencer, Sequencer is a really powerful cinematic tool that comes
with Unreal Engine.
So we can create videos and cinematics and we can essentially play at runtime if we want
to maybe play it during a game cinematic sequence or something that's in engine that plays at
real time or render them as a video file in multiple different formats if you want something
pre-rendered.
We can create gameplay animations so we can bake out animation using Sequencer using that
take recorder that we were referencing before.
So if you set up a series of animations and you maybe add a walk cycle to some kind of
blend into a jump and then jog or something like this and they're all their individual
animations, you can actually play that out and bake it into its own animation which is
a really powerful tool.
We can also trigger events directly from Sequencer.
So if you want a certain event to trigger as the character gets to the middle of their
walk cycle for example or something like this, it will send out an event into Blueprints
and you'll be able to call different events directly from Sequencer.
Sequencer also comes with its own curve editor.
So if you want to refine any of the movement, any camera pans, anything like this, it comes
with its own curve editor which you can see as the icon on that main nav bar right in
the middle, the furthest icon on the right hand side but it's in the middle of that
window.
That's your curve editor.